[Music]
hello and welcome to the session on
DevOps metrics and dashboards we will
see one of the various DevOps metrics
that need to be monitored and measured
and one of the various dashboard tools
to do the same let us begin by
understanding what software metrics are
while we develop software products we
need some mechanism some way of
measuring or validating than what we are
doing meets our customers expectations
not only of the functionality that we
are developing as part of that software
development but also of cost budget of
various resources to spend and the
return on investments on all that cost
all that money that is being spent
metrics can be defined as quantitative
measures that allow the software
engineers to identify the efficiency and
approve the quality of software
processes software projects and the
outcome product this enables software
engineers or project managers or your
stakeholders to adjust software
processes and improve software products
if needed
there are various metrics that can be
measured for software projects you have
balanced scorecards better performance
management tool a semi standard
structured report supported by design
methods and automation tools that can be
used by managers to keep track of
execution of activities by the different
team members within their reporting
structure and monitor the consequences
arising from any of these actions you
can have a software bug which can be
measured or line of code so a bug is an
error or a flaw or a failure or some
kind of fault in the computer program or
system that causes it to produce an
incorrect or unexpected result
or to behave in unintended ways then you
have code coverage so in computer
science code coverage is a measure used
to describe the degree to which the
source code of the
program is executed when a particular
gas with runs a program with high code
coverage measured as a percentage has
more of its source code executed during
testing which suggests that it has a
lower chance of containing undetected
software votes compared to a program
with low code coverage there are many
different metrics that can be used to
calculate the code coverage some of the
most basic ones are the percentage of
subroutines programs and the percentage
of program statements that are called
during execution of the software code
then you have something called
cyclomatic complexity which is a
software metric that is used to indicate
the complexity of a software program it
is a quantitative measure of the number
of linearly independent paths through a
program source code you can have
function points and automated function
points so function points is a unit of
measure to express the amount of
business functionality and information
that a system or product provides to a
user function points are used to compute
functional size measurement of software
the cost and dollars or number of hours
of single unit dis calculated from
previous project data in engineering
maintainability is the ease with which a
project can be maintained in order to
correct effects or the causes repair or
replace faulty components without having
to replace the parts that are working
funny prevent unexpected working
conditions maximize the products used
for life maximize efficiency reliability
and safety meet any new requirements
that you receive from your customer to
implement make future maintenance easier
or able to cope with more changed
environment then you can have something
called number of classes and interfaces
so number of classes and interfaces are
measured to check for code complexity or
even your function point complexity
source line of code S LOC all
so known as line of code is a software
metrics that is used to measure the size
of computer program accounting the
number of lines in the text of the
program source code source line of code
is typically used to predict the amount
of effort that would be required to
develop a program as well as to estimate
programming productivity or
maintainability once a software is
produced in computing a loader is part
of an operating system that is
essentially responsible for loading
programs and libraries in the memory of
your computer it is one of the essential
stages in the process of starting a
program as a place of programs into
memory and prepares them for execution
loading a program involves reading the
content of the executable file
containing the program instructions into
memory and then carrying out the
required preparatory steps to prepare
the executable front-running once
loading is complete the operating system
starts the program by passing control to
the loaded program code in computer
science the runtime or execution time is
the time during which the program is
running or executing in contrast to
other programs Fletch cycle phases such
as compilation time length time load
time a runtime error is detected after
or during the execution state of a
program whereas a compile time error is
detected by the compile time before the
program is ever executed type checking
register allocation code generation code
optimization are typically done at
compile time but may be done at run time
either depending on the particular
language and compiler weighted
microphone points is a modern software
sizing algorithm invented by logical
solutions in the year 2009 which is a
successor to the solid ancestors
scientific method such as Kokomo kosice
Moe maintainability
Dex cyclomatic complexity function
points and ask complexity it produces
more accurate results than traditional
software sizing methodologies while
requiring less configuration and
knowledge from the end-user as most of
the estimation is based on automatic
measurement of an existing source code
dashboards often provide at a glance
view of various key performance
indicators also called KPIs
relevant for a particular objective or
business process like sales marketing
human resources or production in real
world terms dashboard is another name
for a progress report or a report the
underlying virtues of implementing
DevOps are continued improvement and
development the development and IT
operation teams are expected to
collaborate and the active participants
in this collaboration and innovative
process the objective overall is to
ensure smooth functioning of the
application with release interruptions
build instinct dashboards for a distinct
software ultimately a dashboard is a
common platform or a framework that
enables you to manage issues so more
than the technicalities it is important
to nurture a culture that encourages the
adoption of DevOps approach the idea
here is to enable self learning and self
improvement among software developers
operations engineers our regular basis
change is difficult and while on a
transformation journey it is important
to realize the objectives of the project
or task at hand the objective helps
structured metrics for tracking the
overall development process for the
respective teams devops dashboards
enable system admins and developers to
remain updated with software
applications key performance metrics
like uptime low time API calls CPU
processes memory usage and various
other components that ensure that your
production environment is stable and
your customer and user experience is
stable software development lifecycle is
a journey of various ups and downs
things get broken and fixed throughout
the cycle DevOps dashboards monitors the
process and helps you to spot bugs
before you get flooded with user issues
user feedback and tickets
as mentioned earlier building metrics on
the DevOps dashboard totally depends on
the project objectives creating a DevOps
dashboard totally depends on and is
highly influenced by your own
requirements and challenges it is a
reflection of your projects need at the
overall approach of the team so it is
recommended to create edit repeat and
build focused dashboard metrics that
enhance the visibility of the project
process and issues additionally it
incorporates response time usage of
resources issues and errors and a user
feedback any other aspect that you feel
is important for a speedy delivery for
example tracking CPU usage for
individual internal api's helps the
operations team to evaluate the issues
with performance and accordingly to take
necessary actions during the course of
the project you need dashboard for
tracking the application for assessing
of the team's progress for tracking the
core performance api's and making them
visible for all the objective is to get
the process going collaboratively and
deliver it at the same speed with the
necessary quality quality and speed are
at the core of DevOps approach a key
reason why leading enterprises across
the globe leverage the synergy between
development and operations teams with an
indicated DevOps model DevOps culture is
majorly driven not just by the synergy
but also by the underlying
need for continuous collaboration and
delivery
there are various DevOps metrics on
which you can create dashboards
frequency of deployments which is
basically a metrics that will keep a tab
on the pre on the frequency of deploying
the new code it will help track the
deployment process by team members which
is a very critical activity for any
project moreover it is all pervasive and
is applicable across projects you can
measure tracking change and it is
absolutely critical to track the user
stories associated with the project and
most importantly setting the parameters
to track the complexity of the changes
occurring in the project you can track
the lead time which is software
application development follows a
process of development to deployment
when new code is developed and
successfully deployed into production
cycle time is a key indicator to
determine efficiency in the process
where it helps a team to understand the
areas of improvements ultimately the
metrics helps the team to get a better
hold of the project's development track
percentage of deployments fail so you
need to track the percentage of
deployments that had led to outage or
any negative feedback from your customer
from your user by the nature of DevOps
approach it is expected to build quality
right from the beginning
rather than post development as an
afterthought experts suggests to review
this metrics as a team to effectively
keep track of negative sentiment in the
project's mean time to recovery is
another useful metrics recovery and
resilience is critical in any project as
it will help build market readiness of
your software application mean time to
recovery is an ideal process of tracking
complex issues and failures assessing
the ability of the team to handle
fundamental change and be able to bounce
back various performance metrics can be
incorporated this metrics has term
stable irrespective of any changes in
user feedback or your deployment
indicators it is a key indicator that
the software application is operational
within the defined limits there are
various DevOps dashboards tools
available like ELQ stack graphite keen
i/o lebra no data dog and hygeia the ELQ
stack is essentially a combination of
three open-source products from elastic
elastic search and analytics capability
locks acts as the logs aggregator and
Cabana for the fancy - word
visualization today elastic Serge is
pretty much built-in with log stash and
Cabana as an elastics product as well
making integration and setup very simple
but a new deployment rules at the
dashboard follows custom indicators that
you can set up using your apps out these
indicators update in real time allow
them close monitoring and freshly
delivered code taking its first steps
after being uploaded to production it is
free but there are elastic pay plans
that include different levels of
professional support for the tool
graphite is an open source tool written
in Python for storing data and providing
graphs and visualizations of it on
demand it does not collect any data
itself but instead works with other
tools for the purpose graph Anna is an
open source tool that provides a metrics
dashboard and graph editor for graphite
it essentially enhances what you can get
from graphite and provides more features
graphite and graph Anna are designed to
be language agnostic also worth noting
is the hosted graphite which essentially
offers graphite and Gravano as paid
software as a service model Keane IO is
a software and service analytics
infrastructure platform it collects the
data use
by from a wide range of possibilities
and it's api's performed analytics and
visualization tasks at your request it's
designed around providing flexibility
and choice to users from whom other
visualization and metrics aren't
satisfied if you can't get the exact
data you want from other tools but can't
or don't want to build your own custom
analytics infrastructure if analytics is
a primary focus or concern for you and
you want more than what an
out-of-the-box solution provides then
DevOps Keene IO is a good tool for you
liberato is a hosted service for
monitoring and managing cloud
applications liberato can create custom
dashboards and seconds without the need
to set up or deploy any software it
focuses on graphics and visuals to
create a very smooth look and feel
compared to other dashboards it recently
became part of SolarWinds if you want to
be able to work with highly customized
metrics and reports if you want
beautiful visualizations and better
learning for the data that you send in
liberado is the tool that will answer
all of this for you data dog is again a
software service monitoring tool
targeted for DevOps teams that take data
from your app and wide range of other
tools and provides metrics and
visualizations it unifies data produced
from your infrastructure and software
into one location they are currently
built around aggregating and presenting
data rather than performing analytics if
you want a DevOps focus tool that works
with an extensive ecosystem of other
tools if you want a tool that presents
you with a unified view of data
generated across your hardware and
software data dog is a good choice
hygeia gives developers a visual way to
track progress across the development
pipeline the dashboard automatically
refreshes every minute after tracking a
project's progress across six different
areas features code repository built
quality monitoring and also deployment
for example the code
the window displays information
regarding coding activities number of
commits per day number of committers and
other current coding trends hygeia
dashboard only supports the following
tools to plug in those plugins can be
written to integrate with other tools
and solutions features like JIRA version
1 code repositories like github
subversion build tools like jenkins
Hudsons for quality sonar cube cucumber
selenium and for deployment IBM
urbancode deploy hey once become an
expert in cloud computing then subscribe
to simpler Channel and click here to
watch more such videos turn it up and
get certified in cloud computing click
here